all right do you have the right health
insurance for you and your family now is
the time to be asking that question and
there is a phone number you can call
right now to ask a question to some
experts who have answers when it comes
to
what health insurance is best for you
this is an open enrollment period it's a
critical time when you can sign up and
uh discover what is best for you
individually and for your loved ones as
well joining us more to talk about that
is sebastian de freitas of select health
sebastian thanks so much for joining us
today this open enrollment period has
been extended this year right it got
extended and you know we are so excited
that we can help you know our the
community here in nevada to understand
their choices and enroll in a health
plan select health is a non-for-profit
health plan we have a mission which is
helping people live the healthiest life
possible and with that in mind we want
everybody our community our members to
remain healthy and we offer personalized
service high quality care and we are an
integrated health plan part of
intermountain healthcare and we offer
health plans in nevada so what are the
steps someone should take if they're not
sure if they have
the right insurance health insurance
that is a great question because a lot
of us who were covered before maybe are
making another type of evaluation do i
have the right plan maybe i have other
family members i want to include maybe
my health or family situation change so
i need to revise you know those type of
options so we want everybody to remember
that at the deadline to elect a health
plan this year uh for 2022 is january
15th for an effective date of february
first and to emphasize how important
that is if you miss that deadline what
do you have to do if you don't have
insurance great point if you miss that
deadline you might have to wait for the
next open rumble window unless you have
a special situation throughout the year
which could be unlikely so we want
everybody if they can to make that
decision before january 15. all right
sebastian thanks so much you're going to
be with us until seven o'clock tonight
here in the call a phone bank call the
number on your screen 702-650-1101
and get your questions answered when it
comes to health insurance rocky